Here with my faithful Lieutenant Sergey
and we're off to the Wagah
International Border Crossing.
This is what separates India and Pakistan.
Most likely you've seen it online.
It's that very theatrical performance
both nation states put on.
But what we're gonna
get into here in this video
is comparing and contrasting
the two performances.
So today
we're gonna get into the Indian side.
I'm gonna show the Indian side and tomorrow
the Pakistani side.
[motorcycle]
♪ Indian music ♪
In 1947, after 300
years of British occupation
the British left and two
separate countries emerged
India and Pakistan.
It's got the feeling like we're
going to some sporting event.
How much?
-50, Sir.
♪ Indian music ♪
It's about a one kilometer walk
into the crossing.
First impressions
feels quite festive
'lotta flags, 'lotta hats, 'lotta shirts
some food situations and then a massive
flag through the haze there.
You love our India?
Me too, brother.
-Thank you, sir.
-Where's your hat?
But you got your hand painted.
So that's cool.
Are you guys ready for this?
-Yes.
You're ready, you're excited?
-You are from?
-USA.
-Yeah.
-Good, good.
-One selfie?
-Let's selfie it.
So I wonder if the Pakistani
side will have the same
energy, the same fire,
the same friendliness.
Couldn't record back
there, a lot of barbed wire.
A lot of security and they're
taking it pretty seriously obviously.
Go?
Okay.
Straight?
[Speaking Indian]
Oh cool.
Pakistani flag over there.
Have some stands that are filling up here.
I guess this is where
the performance happens.
I'm going over here.
This border ceremony started in 1959
and has happened daily ever since.
The border between India and Pakistan is
There are only five crossing points.
[crowd noise]
Patriotic music blasts from the speakers
and organized dance takes over the tarmac.
♪ Indian music ♪
So I look over here to the Pakistani side
and it just really feels empty and distant.
♪ Indian music ♪
Here you can see a family
crossing between the two countries.
A very small percentage
of Indians and Pakistanis
know what the other side is like.
It's really not easy for
either nationality to get a visa
to visit the other country.
♪ Indian music ♪
Though the two
countries are very different
the border splits the
Punjabi people apart.
So both sides share linguistic,
culinary, and cultural similarities.
This video is about the BSF.
The Indian Border Security Forces.
The BSF started in the
Indian-Pakistani war of 1965.
Where the largest tank battle
happened since World War II.
It was a 17 day war.
Thousands of people died on each side.
The BSF now has 257,000 personnel
and it is known as
India's first line of defense.
♪ patriotic music ♪
♪ military music ♪
The gates open and the rivals
start with a sportsmanlike handshake.
♪ military music ♪
Check out this Indian soldier
he's a master of combining
gymnastic moves with a militant march.
♪ military music ♪
[announcer speaking Indian]
[crowd responds]
[announcer continues]
♪  music continues ♪
The horns start, faces become more serious.
[horns]
♪ military bugle ♪
♪ bugles continue ♪
Yes, the two countries
are political enemies
but there is a unity in the
way they've choreographed
this machismo-driven ballet together.
Today I came from
India in front of us here.
Went all the way to Lahore, Pakistan.
Which is about 45 minutes away
and then came back...
[car horn]
and now we're catching
the border from this side.
to see the other perspective.
The security coming in here
was much tighter.
A lot of checkpoints.
We put an official in the back of the car.
The guy I was driving with
knew the official
and we put him in the back
and then we got through all
the checkpoints super quick.
What do you think it's
gonna be like today?
What is this gonna be like?
-It's gonna be surprising.
Okay, so here on the Pakistani side
the approach is very much the same.
Patriotic music gets louder each
step as I get closer to the border.
♪ loud music ♪
The Pakistani stadium is much smaller
and it's almost to scale of
each country's populations.
[crowd cheering]
Both sides have the same chant of Zindabad.
Even though I'm just meters away
from where I was the day before
it feels a world away.
The colors are different, the clothes
are different, the drum beats harder.
Thank you, brother.
[crowd cheering]
The Rangers are Pakistan's
equivalent of India's BSF.
There are 25,000 rangers in total.
So these rangers, from first impression.
They're much bigger
and more grizzly looking
than the BSF guys.
The rangers have rockstar-like status
and there are better chances to
interact with them versus the Indian side.
Both sides have the ringleaders
to fire up the spectators.
Different styles but equally as effective.
[crowd cheering]
♪ patriotic music ♪
Because of the smaller size of the
stadium it feels much more intimate
and connected.
[crowd cheering]
[announcers speaking]
The huge bonus on the
Pakistani side is the live drum.
Two women start the
parade just like the Indian side
♪ military music ♪
[crowd cheering]
[crowd cheers]
♪ music continues ♪
[announcer chants and crowd answers]
I didn't remember seeing
a sword on the Indian side
but I feel more aggression
from the rangers.
♪ military music ♪
If I had to choose between
seeing an angry BSF soldier
or a ranger in a dark alleyway
I'd definitely prefer the BSF soldier.
Look, both could easily
dismantle me in two seconds
but the ranger's size and
intensity are unmatched.
[crowd gets louder]
[air horns]
[cheering]
♪ military music ♪
They're true performers with
little details like mustache twirling.
[announcer shouting]
<He's sitting down now but
he's gonna come through.
Pride towards national
identity feel equally as strong
on both sides of the border.
♪ music continues ♪
[clapping in rhythm]
♪ military bugles ♪
Whatever side I was on,
it connected me more with that country.
So if someone doesn't have
the chance to sit on the other side
then it feels like a distant world away.
♪ bugles continue ♪
[loud cheering]
Even though there is that serious rivalry
and distrust between the countries
there is also that unity in the celebration
as each side needs the other to perform.
♪ patriotic music ♪
[whistle blows]
I can tell you from my
experience that the locals are open
hospitable and friendly
on both sides of this divided
and very entertaining border.
Like and subscribe if you
want to support this channel
Hit the notification bell to be
the first to see my next video.
Many more videos about Pakistan
and other parts of the world coming soon.